there's ideas of pants like ism where
people believe that whatever
consciousness is is a fundamental part
of reality it's almost like a physics
law do you think what's your views on
consciousness do you think it has this
this deep part of reality or is it
something that's deeply human and
constructed by us humans start nice and
light yeah and easy easy I think I asked
you today has actually proven answer so
yeah hypothesis so yeah I mean I should
clarify is this all speculation yeah and
I'm not an expert in any of these talk
to topics and I'm not God but I think
that consciousness is probably um
something that can be fully explained
within the laws of physics I think that
our you know bodies and brains and and
the universe and and at the quantum
level is so rich and complex I'd be
surprised if we couldn't find a room for
consciousness there and why should we be
conscious why are we aware of ourselves
that is a very strange and interesting
and important question and I think for
the next few thousand years we're going
to have to believe in answers purely on
faith but my guess is that we will find
that you know within the configuration
space of possible arrangements of the
universe there are some that contain
memories of others literally uh Julian
Barbour calls them time capsule states
where you're like yeah not only do I
have a scratch on my arm but also this
state of the universe also contains a
memory in my head of being scratched by
my cat three days ago and for some
reason those kinds of states of the
universe are more plentiful or more
likely when you say those states the
ones would that contain memories of its
past or ones that contain memories of
its past and have degrees of
consciousness just the first part
because the I think the consciousness
then emerges from the fact that
state of the universe that contains
fragments or memories of other states is
one where you're going to feel like
there's time you're going to feel like
yeah things in the happened in the past
and I don't know what'll happen in the
future because these states don't
contain information about the future for
some reason those kind of states are
either more common more plentiful or you
could use the anthropic principle and
just say well they're extremely rare but
until you are in one or if you are in
one then you can ask questions like
you're asking me on this podcast slide
questions but yeah it's like what why
are we conscious well because if we
weren't we wouldn't be asking why we
were
you